and
finally new rule someone has to convince
President Biden that if he runs again
he's going to turn the country back over
to Trump and
go and go down in history as Ruth Bader
Biden the person who doesn't know when
to quit and so does great damage to
their party and their country all of us
who like Joe Biden have been struggling
lately with the political situation in
the Democratic Party an incumbent we
admire who acquitted himself well in a
first term but who even members of his
own party don't want to see run for a
second despite a touching letter of
recommendation from Aston Kutcher and
munes I kid they shouldn't have gotten
for that if you ask me do I think
Joe Biden can do the job of President my
answer is an unequivocal yes he can do
the job do I love everything no but
that's every president but government
work is done in small quiet rooms like
the Oval Office and in that setting
Joe's compassion and centuries of
experience are pluses and he's generally
made good decisions that got us out of
Afghanistan handled Ukraine kept the
economy chugging finally got us
rebuilding infrastructure returned to
sense of normaly there is a term for Joe
Biden but not
to
because while he can do the job what he
can't do is run for it our campaign
season is long and it gets icy in New
Hampshire to those who say he beat Trump
once he'll do it again I say things
change they always do the parade moves
on 2024 is not 2020 in so many key ways
including yes Biden being four years
older you can be a National Treasure and
still be too old for the job if I'm on a
plane and the pilot says this is your
captain Buzz
Aldren I'm getting
[Applause]
off Mitch McConnell has served Satan
well
but when he starts buffering during a
[Laughter]
speech and it and it appears his soul is
leaving his
body it's
time I have made it a theme on this show
to rail against agism the last
acceptable Prejudice in America I've
tried to make the argument that judging
by age is wrong because we all age so
differently some people are old when
they're 45 and others are spry at 90 so
it should always be a caseby casee basis
but the credibility of my argument
against agism rests on the honest
calling out of people when it is time to
go that's what case by case means at an
event last weekend Biden referred to LL
Cool J as llj
coolj say what you want about Trump but
he remembers Kanye's
[Applause]
name look at some point perception
becomes reality what matters is voters
think Biden's too old what matters is
he's going to lose to Trump who's almost
the same age but his age just doesn't
read like Biden's maybe it's because
Trump is insane maybe it's because he's
always a ball of white hot anger but for
whatever reason he looks robust and Joe
looks like his own skeletal
remains if if if this was 1860 when Joe
first
ran this would not be an issue you
didn't have to look good and there was
no ubiquitous media to pick on every
little mistake the only people who saw
the Lincoln Douglas debates were the
people who went to them but Joe's
debates next year will be televised to
all and I don't think he's going to look
good yes Trump is old too but Trump is
like Kiss he puts on the face paint in
the
wig and he looks the same as he did in
1978 far from being the only one who
could beat Trump in 2024 Biden May well
be the only Democrat who would lose to
him James Carville told me any Centrist
Democrat around 50 or 60 would get 55%
of the vote and I believe him you know
that future headlines bit we do well the
most predictable headline ever is
presidential race tied two weeks before
every election it's always tied no
matter who is running the vast majority
just vote for the D or the r but Biden
is the one Democrat who gives pause to
so many people even in his own party
Andrew Sullivan makes the necessary
point that a new nominee for the
Democrats would shift the dynamic
immediately Trump would be the tired old
guy retread hanging on to the past and
the Democrat would now be the future let
the Republicans be the party with the
candidate who babbles nonsense shouts at
the TV and can't do
[Applause]
ramps Joe you did Noble service for your
country and you checked that big box the
president of the United States of course
as a politician you're naturally going
to say but the work is not finished of
course not it never is but it's time to
let someone else finish it you don't
want to go down as Ruth Bader
Biden America is calling Joe and it's
saying that's not our car Grandpa we're
over
here
that